Who loves you, people?
Look this way news media! A
celebrity is throwing away
his hard earned cash! Everyone
pay attention to me!
Ugh, it's only 1 dollar bills
folks. Don't bother.
No, it's still free spendable
money, this is a huge story.
Dollars are like the new penny.
Yeah! Cash is for poor people!
What is wrong with you bozos?
Just riot over the damn money
already!
Well, nothing to see here I
guess.
Whoa! Jesus Christ my ankle!
Oh my god! American singer
songwrite Beyonce is hurt!
Somebody help her!
Ring the alarm!
Irreplaceable pop icon
and independent woman
Beyonce has been injured.
What more can you give us?
Details are sketchy at
this point but we do know
Beyonce is a survivor
and presumably
she will keep on surviving.
But what happened?
Well Tom I'm being told
she fell on
-All the single dollars.
-All the single dollars?
Bills Bills Bills.
We promised to provide
Blye unflinching coverage
of this harrowing ordeal
of a star gone from Dangerously
in Love to dangerously in peril.
Don't stop watching
Mr. Peanut Butter, take her
home.
Doctors have confirmed that
Beyonce will never perform
again.
This just in- a break in
the story of a Hollywoo heist.
We now go live to the house
of Mr. Peanut Butter
star of Mr. Peanut Butter's
House.
Ah, geez, what did that idiot
do?
Ladies and gentlemen
of the press.
I and I alone stole the D
from the Hollywoo sign.
-Just tell us why'd you do it!
-Oh, I'll tell you why!
I did it all
for my girlfriend. Diane.
Son of a bitch
that literal son of a bitch.
>> You're joining us
Mr. Peanut Butter
has confessed to stealing the D
for his girlfriend Diane
in what many are calling
the most romantic gesture
in the history of romance
and gestures.
We now await the LAPD move
the day they make love a crime
is the day I turn in my badge.